So let us explain
what claims data is.
So medical claims are generated
when a patient visits a doctor.
Medical claims include diagnosis
code, procedures codes,
as well as costs.
Pharmacy claims involve drugs,
the quantity of these drugs,
the prescribing doctor, as
well as the medication costs.
Claims data are
electronically available, they
are standardized, they use
well-established codes.
However, since
humans generate them,
they are not 100% accurate.
And often, under-reporting
is common in the sense
that it's a tedious job
to record these claims,
and as a result, often
people under-report them.
Also, claims for hospital
visits can be vague.
In creating a data
set, our objective
was to assess quality,
health care quality.
So we used a large health
insurance claims database,
and we randomly selected
131 diabetes patients.
The ages ranged between
35 to 55 and the costs
were in the neighborhood
of $10,000 to $20,000.
The period in which these
claims were recorded
were September 1, 2003
to August 31, 2005.
An expert physician
reviewed the claims
and wrote descriptive
notes, like "ongoing use
of narcotics"; "only on Avandia,
not a good first choice drug";
"had regular visits,
mammogram, and immunizations";
"was given home
testing supplies".
After this review,
this expert physician
rated the quality of care on a
two-point scale, poor or good.
Examples included,
I'd say care was poor.
Poorly treated diabetes.
Not an eye exam, but overall
I'd say high quality.
So based on these comments,
we extracted variables.
The dependent variable
was the quality of care.
The independent variables
involve the ongoing use
of narcotics; only on Avandia,
not a good first choice drug;
had regular visits,
mammogram, and immunizations;
was given home testing supplies.
Overall, the
independent variables
involved diabetes
treatment variables,
patient demographics, health
care utilization, providers,
claims, and prescriptions.
The dependent variable was
modeled as a binary variable --
1 for low-quality care and
0 for high-quality care.
This is by its nature
a categorical variable.
It only takes two
possible values.
We have seen linear
regression as a way
of predicting
continuous outcomes.
Of course, we can
utilize linear regression
to predict quality of
care here, but then we
have to round the
outcome to 0 or 1.
Instead, we will
explain in this lecture
how we can use logistic
regression, which
is an extension of
linear regression,
to environments where
the dependent variable is
categorical.
In our case, 0 or 1.